good morning guys it's ryan right here
it is the morning and I have to believe
for work really soon actually I am I'm a
little bit behind I woke up a little
late but then I hide that went on my
YouTube account and then I got all these
notifications the most the biggest
number of notifications I've ever woken
up to and they were all saying the same
thing you gotta watch the final trailer
for the amazing spider-man 2 so I said
to myself [ __ ] work I'm gonna watch this
trailer and be late to work today so
it's a big event
it's the final trailer for spider-man 2
can't wait to watch it and I got to get
to work so let's watch this thing this
one's gonna rock disease in 3
[Music]
eyes
your partner very husband
and ten years what have you been up to
those glasses
I really what design
[Music]
oh my god the way the shot is beautiful
he's armed just the wrist on the wrist
but
we don't want to see us ask you under
surveillance
why is another question of the day what
I thought it was I once talked to the
secrets at cost
[Music]
Richard Parker I have discovered what
Oscorp open to use my research for this
[ __ ] music is making my nipples rise
we have plans for you Peter Parker the
hee
[Music]
shouldn't have [ __ ] a Jamie Foxx man
[Music]
[Applause]
we can change the world
[Music]
music
[Music]
oh my god this movie is gonna be amazing
no pun intended
I'm the only one who can stop the ball
nah
[Music]
this is gonna be the best one
[ __ ] the green gobby
[Music]
other than with you foreigners too
dangerous
sorry I love you don't ring me
[Music]
oh that is gonna be an IMAX 3d
experience I saw the first amazing
spider-man in 3d I was impressed this
movie I'm sure is gonna top the first 3d
experience I thought that was that's the
best trailer they released so far they
save the best for last
you know what a lot of people have been
worried about spider-man 3 syndrome
where there were so many [ __ ] villains
this looks like they're gonna tie it all
in very well it doesn't look like it's
all over the place I I'm so jacked up to
see this [ __ ] film like this could be
the best spider-man we've gotten yet
because spider-man 2 is Kermit in the
woma Tobey Maguire is currently my favor
1 then it goes the amazing spider-man so
this looks like it'll probably take the
spot for Ryan's number 1 this time you
gotta see more of green gobby excited
for it man it's good the effects the
action the mute that if this is the kind
of music that's in the movie wow this is
so worth being late to work anyway guys
thanks for suggesting this to me I'm
glad I woke up to all these
notifications cuz this is the best way
to start my morning better than my usual
routine of jerking off to porn so yeah
it's good and if you're new to the
channel subscribe now how cool would it
be to have those [ __ ] webs every time
you watch a spider-man movie you go
around once just imagining you're
spider-man all the time and this trailer
alone is making me want to be spider-man
that moment where Peter Parker you know
Webb slings Emma Stone's hand and she
stuck so she can't follow Peter I wish I
could do that with every single girl
that has ever chased after me which is
usually someone who is very unattractive
I need to get better at talking to girls